Let me give you a small
help.
That will help you. Think about this.
Think about the solution for this problem.
So I'm going to add example 2.
This is for random variables. So
look how much we've covered so far.
We're making great progress So This Is Random.
variable
and now we are example number two.
Okay, but here's what example one was like.
so this was the random variable of
example 1
so we had let's say we had some seed.
Okay.
This is some ID. This is not a number. That's nothing mathematical just
ID.
and if this seat was
empty
you would get a one.
And then this one.
is let's say with ID for
and it's also assigned.
Meaning it's not vacant. So we have to find the third seat.
Okay.
If you want to that's sorry.
This was supposed to be zero. Let's say there are only three seats.
so this is one this is one feature of the random variable you give
it a
the value Within
a table like it is an actual table.
Well, we don't have a diagram for but it is a table and I
will give you.
it's
probably now we'll count that in a second.
Just bear with me but let me just go ahead and show you the solution for example
two.
Okay.
And then you will be able to solve a problem like this.
so
similar to the previous example, we had y
and we passed to the seat and it would give us the
a corresponding value
Here rather we are talking about.
the number of values
within the table of the random variable.
Okay.
Very simple. Here's how you do it.
S is your experiment?
This is the experiment anything that goes between the parentheses is
the experiment like in the previous example, we had the seat ID. That's the
ID was the experiment.
You are checking for that seat your experimenting
on that seat.
And you want to count.
the total number of chargers
And here's the notation. This is the experiment and that experiment.
translates into this data point
two and three
This is for station one. This is for station two.
Simply the arithmetic and that's what you get.
so on this experiment
at that particular point in time at those both stations the total
number of charges that were being used.
Or five problem. Number two the difference
between the total number of charges in use and Station 1
versus Station 2.
So two charges are used are being used.
At Station 1 3 charges are being used as Station 3.
Excuse me.
Two charges are being used at station one.
three charges I've been used as Station to
random variable y
will tell you the difference between the two.
Now we will get minus 1.
You understand the difference is one like if
we take the absolute value of this number, it will be 1.
And this one is a mistake. This is supposed to be easy.
Okay. So ignore this is supposed to be Z.
uh Z the third random variable Z
says what is the maximum number of charges in
active use at both stations for this
particular experiment?
Again, we come back to the random Bible notation.
This is supposed to PC. So excuse the mistake Z of
s equals z.
And let's say you had a function that would give
you the maximum of the two.
So you would give it.
Four and one it will tell you that it's four. If you give it three
and five it will give you five. Here's only going to give you
three because obviously three is greater
than greater than two.
Now here's what I meant when I said the random variable.
Is a table.
the random variable
before I talk about this exercise.
and
the thing it's coupled with always the probability distribution.
Keep these try to focus on these two
words random violent property distribution together, they form
an important table.
Or on the a table with two columns.
On the on the First Column you have the values.
That it did random variable can take and in the
second column. You have the probability of each
value.
So for example, if you were talking about flipping a coin.
You have the table would look like this you would have.
a table with four cells
The left column you would have head and tail.
head and tail are the values that the random variable can take
On the other column we would have 0.5 why because
the probability of either one of those values would
be 0.5.
50%
Okay, and we're working our way towards a more
sophisticated table most sophisticated random variable.
Here's an example.
Concrete beam. Let's say you're in manufacturing.
Concrete Construction equip Construction
equipment
a concrete beam May Fail either by sheer
or flexure
There are two things that can make a concrete beam unusable.
Sheer reflection never mind. If you don't know what it what
these two words mean, but if if
The Experience she reflection they cannot be using in the in
the building
suppose that three failed beams are randomly selected.
And the type of failure is determined by each one. Let X
be the number of beams among the three selected that
failed by shear.
So here's what we need to do.
We have a random variable.
a table
that contains the number of beams that
have failed.
specifically by sheer
to have a random variable now we need
to list.
these sample space
correspond and its corresponding outcome in the random variable.
So here's what I'm talking about.
Here's what the random variable minus. Here's what
the random variable would look like minus the probability distribution.
Okay, we're not we haven't company probably probability distribution
yet.
Okay, here's what I mean by random variables though is a
table.
you have
the obviously the letter F stands for flexure.
and as for sheer
the random variable
it contains the number of the three
failed beams.
the three field beams
and
the number of them that failed by the sheer
or a portion of it breaks apart.
for example
the first set of three failed beams
have all failed by flexure.
They have been bent Beyond taking beyond
their usability.
The random variable will tell you that the number
of shears in these three beams is
zero. None of them fail by sheer.
all of them failed by F which stands for flexure
and then you and then you pick and then you go through another pair of
three beams you pick them up.
And you find that two of them have failed by flexure.
One of them has failed because they have issue. They
have a big break.
The random variable will tell you one.
once you
and this is how you construct the table.
for the random variable
Okay, let's move quickly move on to the next one.
So we've looked at.
the first component
like the first part of the most important component the random value in the public distribution the
random variable now, let's look at the probability probability distribution.